hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to NOx time or also I have
some very good news I got some sleep
hooray sleep it's the best thing in the
world if you didn't know I was in a
livestream for about 12 hours uh this
weekend for cyndago and they live in
South Carolina so I flew there and flew
back within about two or three days I
think two days and I've been getting
about four hours of sleep for the past
few nights probably the past week
actually but I finally got some so with
Lou so let's fix that problem by giving
myself nightmares with another indie
horror game what do you got for me aim
you were highly rated on games old but
I've been alluded to before on that
alluded to disillusioned oh I know that
sound that's the traditional sound of
using when you have to use royalty-free
things okay but I won't judge
I shan't not judge until I see the full
extent of your brutality on my soul so
show me whoa well alright thy door don't
get in my way who are you
whoa okay then you're a little low res
but I can see how you'd be creepy I'll
just back away slowly
no well alright then that cap wasn't
there before right I just I just
overlooked him please tell me I just
overlooked them actually that'd be worse
if I overlooked them okay so oh hi Hey
creeping up on me I don't think so
I don't think so you're gonna be so what
am I supposed to do just go back and
forth until I find something I'm glad to
see you here hmm okay well then you're
gonna play one of these sorry yeah huh
well I'm ready for you I know kungfu I
got the best beatable Oh skills in the
nation you not know what to be a blow
thing is there's an animation about that
in the distance that's oddly creepy
little low-res but I'll get over it am I
just gonna be walking back and forth in
between two rooms waiting for him to pop
up on me like boo and then I go air whoa
oh you changed pardon you want to run
that by me again did someone fart down
there okay okay the only reason that's a
little creepier than I think it should
be is cuz it's kind of mannequin asked
and I don't like ya Anakin's don't see
him he's gonna pop up next oh hey that's
the same room it's got longer all of a
sudden again okay you brought friends I
love friends friends of the wall okay
well that didn't work I just kind of
bumped up against them well I'll just
I'll be on my way you know I got a busy
day ahead of me
of not being around you guys so this
takes a lot of hard work you can escape
can i okay well why do your claws turn
red huh
you want some you all say to me you all
got bloody eyes some teeth missing
you're all identical twins huh we've got
for me oh god it's still creepy I don't
care you're not a threat to me
maybe excuse me hi hi hi hi hi okay I'll
just be on my way then
I got those knives over there can I use
them in any way yeah that lady's bright
all right let me get another good look
at this
oh uh god that's beautiful okay let me
just go on my way then all right then
okay they don't want to show their ugly
faces anymore they just saw my face and
they got incredibly jealous at how ugly
I am okay what do you got now Oh
but I love but but what anybody anybody
want to show themselves and preferably
in a jump scary fashion that's gonna
make me startled I do put it down there
I see something okay all right then
not sure what that's all about but
you're making a leg issue I don't know
if that means I'm being infected by the
knocks time or disease are you behind me
no come out come out wherever you are
I'm coming to find you come out come out
he's right behind you oh not sure what I
walked up on all right you'll come back
anyway
can I just wrap my head around what the
hell just happened cuz what the hell
just happened that's what I'd like to
know all righty why are my legs so itchy
all of a sudden what is this game doing
to me if anyone if anyone else's legs
are itchy all of a sudden maybe there's
some shared experience going on here
maybe we're all gonna duck thought I saw
something did I not see something I
thought I saw something there was
definitely something hmm come how it's
cold boy why are all my god my legs have
never been it's year than they are right
now holy crap why you have no other
choice
do I wait a minute though is this a
choice go one way or the other I'll
choose the door yeah
stop slamming in my face like that
all righty then okay that's what you
want to do wait where'd my flashlight go
hey my flashlights in there he took away
my flashlight my legs are still really
itchy everywhere what did I get myself
in oh okay all right
locked
let's eat Oh
all right is anybody in here
my head's itchy every part of me is
gonna get to you but say it's all my
skin off this never happened to me
before
aah what why
oh hi Freddy Freddy is that you please
get me out of here maybe how do I get
over there oh yeah yeah yeah you keep
looking at me keep you keep your eyes on
me man keep your eyes on me Oh where'd
you go where'd you go where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where'd you go go go go go
you go where'd you go go go go go okay
okay okay you can't get away from me
oh all right where'd you go you don't
understand this guy this is like I'm not
even exaggerating about this i I've got
the weird I don't even understand it
what the [ __ ] is going on my body's
falling apart right here on camera hey
hey hey it's not like it one location is
all over this game it better would be
honestly I must have missed something in
here but I didn't see it cuz it's too
dark it may be brighter for you guys so
you guys are seeing things that I'm
obviously not cuz they turn up the
brightness for you guys let's just
remember I'm wandering around in pitch
blackness
Oh toilet key where was that was that
there before cuz I was wandering around
a little bit probably you guys didn't
see much it oh my god why why they see
legs this has never happened to me
before I'm losing my mind
huh okay okay right now not okay oh my
goodness gravy okay so I just gotta take
this key jam it into wherever the hell
the toilet is because it's the toilet
yeah that's the toilet okay I am part of
you are you then why are you in the
toilet can I have that I think I got it
did I I'm not going well I wish I could
see am you what do you get for me it's
in the toilets huh oh all right then
huh uh huh okay all right Oh key yes
thank you can this get me back to my
flashlight because it really would like
that please thank you did I hear a noise
I heard a noise hi hey buddy
Hey I can't even see your face right now
oh boy I'll just take this thank you see
this is my world my world okay you can
have your world as long as I can have my
flashlight okay my buddy's still there
oh yeah he's still there how you doing
friend oh oh that you live in whatever
whatever
don't tell me how to live my life I know
what I'm doing it okay all right ain't
no real threat yeah just a loud noise
running down my face ain't that big a
deal is that music why is there music
all of a sudden why do I need music all
of a sudden this seems around the final
I'm not ready don't do this to me I'm
not ready to leave I wanna stay in your
world just a little bit longer
Oh long than in the hallway oh well
that's better
Oh Oh Johnny just really narrow oh I'm
going down now apparently oh oh okay
okay all right okay who did that who did
that and why who did that and what why
give me a second black again it she
don't know why Oh
gate in here okay who's playing the
drums
Sarah festive marching band or maybe a
drum corps down the hallway that I
should know about I should warn them
leave unless I'm really the mass
murderer keeping everyone here it's
always a possibility
okay so there was another like way oh I
see so this is okay okay all right so
there's another way to go
of course I fall into the goddamn narrow
maze okay so that just goes back as it
was it did something open here no no
it's just a light on the corner of the
desk okay err y'all clue clue clue clue
and every night and every night what God
you could talk to me more than all right
I won't go that way then fine jeez
thanks for leading me through the maze
again with the bass drum in the
background calm down a little bit your
cue will come oh all righty then
okay oh they're gone now are they not
gone I think they're not gone I just
can't see him cuz dark they probably
been there the whole time I just wasn't
able to see him all right so that's
blocked off this goes this way this goes
over here this goes down y'all one of
these days I'm gonna get out of here
maybe or maybe I'll never ever leave
bass drummer is that you see a dot on
the floor wave over there I'm coming for
you coming for you baby coming for you
oh come for you okay you're trapped in
it I get it yeah I'm trapped in your
world woop did you do something about it
huh what you got I spend enough time
trapped inside my own mind whoa
oh man that's creepy as hell all right
then I'll just follow the lights try not
to touch any weird shadow people he's so
cool though that's a neat little effect
I mean then I know the rest of this was
low res but kind of using the glow of
the flashlight to be able to show that
there are things here creepy whoa Jesus
what huh I'm glad to see you here again
you can escape but you'll come back
anyway you have no other choice you
can't get away from me I am part of you
this is my world that you live in and
every night you're trapped in it okay
you kind of go back and forth on this
little ass oh okay oh okay I gotcha
see nightmare disorder also known as
dream anxiety disorders asleep disorder
characterized by frequent nightmares a
person experiencing nightmare disorder
would have trouble going through
everyday tasks the anxiety and lack of
sleep caused by fearful dreams would
hinder the individual from completing
everyday jobs efficiently incorrectly
well isn't this ironic oh that I just
happened to talk about my lack of sleep
lately so anyway thank you all so much
for watching hope you enjoyed the little
jump scares in this one it wasn't bad
for the limitations on the graphics it
kind of made up for it like a little bit
of environment things I mean a little
too reliant on jump scares but hey what
can you do in an indie horror game it
was still a fun experience so thank you
all so much for watching check out my
other scary games that I played in the
playlist down below in the description
over there and it's colleague hundred
and sixty videos here so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next
and excuse me I'm trying to be a little
bit more tender